so did you prepare for jake cardio wise
yeah i worked hard yes yeah i did but it
was i told you i
started training for my i mean once once
i had my hip surgery they said uh you
know for the first six weeks you can't
even walk
and it was hard for me to listen to him
because by week
four and a half five i was feeling
pretty good i want to give him my
crutches but i'm like you know what this
is for the rest of my life
and if you get the so if you get the
real hip replacement there's no
wrestling there's no nothing right so
that's the next step so okay i'm gonna
take this seriously i do my crush of the
six weeks the next six weeks it's still
like really low weight bearing can't yes
do anything you know so then i get done
with the three months which is like
january and i'm like okay i should start
working out so i started riding a bike a
little bit and then
okay i'm now i'm fat i'm [ __ ] fat i'm
gonna get in better shape because i
don't do anything so i'm actually start
working out and uh and then that
happened right so i'm like okay well now
i got three months and
this gives me a good reason to get back
in shape and
um
you know i knew i wasn't going to be a
full-time boxer so it's like how do i
put a boxing camp together so i found
you know i had my ultimate mike rhodes
he came up and kind of
lived with me ish kind of thing for
three months uh i found a couple of this
guy k9 out of michigan he came over
three weeks he was great i went to
freddie roach for a week so i kind of
like you know try to get as many good as
ideas as i could and my thought was like
okay well if this dude sucks
i can just be tough and you know block a
few punches get him tired and then beat
him up if he's good that's probably not
much of my do about in the next three
months because i'm i'm i was never good
at boxing in the first place all of my
stand up in mixed martial arts was
predicated on how do i get through the
two or three punches that are gonna come
at me in the time i need to get a hold
of them you know it's all you only have
to make two or three of the myths and
then boom you're on top of them at least
for me
um that was all my striking was
predicated on it wasn't about hey i'm
gonna do damage on the feet in order to
make something else happen it was like
how do i clear this
barrier get a hold of you and if you i
actually did the math one time i think i
got a takedown
if you include the knockout round
against mazvidal i got to take down
every round except two so it was like it
was like 53 out of 55 rounds in mma i
gotta take down wow somewhere somewhere
in there
you